what tips do you have uh if somebody
asks you and they see all your success
from starting YouTube and they're
thinking about starting a channel uh
what advice do you give them stay
consistent and experiment that's it
that's it you you just try and try and
try you try 20 different videos and like
sometimes we like okay I'm putting out
10 pieces of content there it's all the
same like if it's all the same it's not
going to work you have to try role plays
so I don't know do comedy like just go
out there and try different things so
your you mentioned before you're kind of
evolving a little bit in your brand how
has your brand evolved you mentioned
you're getting into fashion and so uh
what is kind of your thinking there and
what it means to reinvent yourself or
evolve as a Creator yeah so because um I
raised a around as a Creator they so
investors when they invest in creators
or startups anything they're betting
that they can invest in 10 creators and
one of them is going to become the Jeff
basos of creators so what is Jeff basos
of creat like who is that person and
when I think about it these are people
who are getting big contracts right who
are making like tens of millions of
dollars but not just because they're
posting content like you can't get to
the C Celebrity level just as a content
creator you need to be a media person
like I was on the panel with Patrick
Star yesterday and he he said he got 400
million views on his YouTube channel and
at the same time he sells millions of
item items of his makeup at Sephora I
have two billion views on my channels
but I don't sell that like this is not
what I'm doing business-wise like and if
I go to Sephora I would probably fail
right now so being a media person and
being a Creator um are two different
things and this is what I'm trying to
figure out next how do you go from just
being a Creator when everything that you
do just depends on you making content
versus how do I become this celebr
whatever you call Media person where
companies create content about you
because you're exciting you're
interesting they want to see you so
Patrick has a really bright personality
I'm trying to figure out what is that
for me how are you incorporating some of
that new content is it going into some
of your videos what channel is that
going on or is it also other platforms
are you embracing other platforms it's
going everywhere it's just I Am shifting
like with education or business I think
the maximum number of views you can get
like consistently like a million is
really good yeah people who are in
entertainment or like lifestyle they get
10 million views consistently 20 million
views consistently so I'm trying to even
like for educational stuff I just
recorded a collab with Leo gonzale do
you know the he's like one of my
favorite creators right now he's so fun
so we we did like basic English versus
American English I say a phrase he says
a phrase so it's fun it's not like I'm
teaching something like grammar it's
just just fun to watch for everyone
Americans I did a a similar collab with
an Australian Creator like I am trying
to bring it uh into the entertainment
World kind of so that everyone can
understand if you enjoyed this content
and want to take your YouTube channel to
the next level just click or tap the
link on the screen or go to tube 1K
challenge.com to join our next live
YouTube challenge you'll learn our best
tips and strategies that are working
here at thinkk media and I think you'll
love it